hay que recordar que es la primera vez
de la historia de chile que un gabinete
tendrá más mujeres que hombres serán 14
las ministras frente a 10 ministros y
también un hecho muy importante el hecho
de que el cargo más importante el
ministerio de interior estará a cargo de
una mujer además de eso claras
referencias a los
detenidos-desaparecidos a las heridas de
la dictadura pero también a las heridas
del estallido social vamos a reparar ha
dicho en relación a todas aquellas
personas que probablemente
sufrieron violaciones a los derechos
humanos durante el estallido social que
se quedaron sin ojos en una drama que
continúa vigente muy vivo en chile ha
mencionado el hecho de que se retiran
las querellas es decir que se otorga una
de las principales demandas de los
movimientos sociales de la revuelta que
en los presos llamados presos políticos
aquellos presos que fueron detenidos por
participar en la lucha van a quedar
libres muchos otros elementos volveremos
a hacer somos profundamente
latinoamericanos queremos que se vuelva
a escuchar
la voz del sur en este momento y en este
mundo cambiante un discurso en el que se
ha hecho alusión a todo como tú bien
mencionadas a los temas de cambio
climático al tema del agua que es
central puesto que chile es el único
país en el mundo donde el agua es de
propiedad privada a alterar el sistema
de
redistribución de la riqueza a que ésta
sea de una forma más justa a la cara de
los pensionados que viven con pensiones
mínimas mientras el sistema privado
lucra con esos fondos de retiro con esas
con esas pensiones
muchas muchas alusiones podríamos estar
toda la noche analizando el discurso de
evonik en un día marcado también por los
simbolismos es un presidente que aparece
sin corbata que lo hace en un acto tan
protocolario como el que pasó esta
mañana con una banda presidencial que ha
sido elaborada por un sindicato de
costureras revolucionarias todo en su
gobierno las mujeres vestidas de morado
de verde todo hace referencia a la marca
a la guía al nuevo chile que se trata de
construir y que como él bien dijo no va
a ser fácil
enfrentar dificultades con un profundo
también sentimiento autocrítico que
también ha marcado la campaña y en la
historia de vor y el ser capaz de
reconocer sus propios errores y otro
hecho no menor que mencionó también se
hará
se cuidara el efecto mental que tiene la
pandemia de todos nosotros hay que
recordar que el propio boliche en un
momento de su trayectoria política
reconoció haber sufrido
problemas de depresión o problemas de
afección psicológica